Lee: I moon people on a daily basis.
Anthony: Okay that's fine.
Happy to have you.
Anthony: Hey guys Anthony here for Dnews.
Got Lee Newton here with me from Sourcefed.
More videos!
So Lee, you know how people blame stuff on
the full moon like werewolves, crazy people,
coyote ugly songs.
Well it turns out that the scientists at the
University of Basil in Switzerland now have
evidence that lunar cycles and sleep behaviors
are actually connected.
Lee: I knew it!
No I'm mess during a full moon.
Every time a full moon comes around, my communications
all messed up.
Wait that might be mercury in retrograde.
I oftentimes get the two confused.
Science is hard man.
Anthony: Well the University monitored the
brain patterns and the eye movements of 30
volunteers and they found that even today,
with all our night masks and ambien and white
noise machines, humans still respond to the
geophysical rhythms of the moon.
Lee: Turns out that round a full moon, brain
activity in the areas that relate to deep
sleep drop by 30 percent.
It also took people five minutes longer to
sleep and they slept twenty minutes less,
which explains werewolves.
Anthony: Does it?
You know also Lee, I told you, werewolves
are not real.
Lee: I think the jury's still out on that
one.
Anthony: I don't know if a jury can be out
because it's kinda science.
Lee: Ok cool.
Crush my dreams a little bit.
That's fine.
Anthony: I'm sorry.
Lee: Eh it's fine.
Can't argue with science.
Now the idea of a full moon being responsible
for synchronizing human behavior has been
around forever, but that whole electricity
thing tends to get in the way of the moon's
influence.
Anthony: However this study shows that the
moon really does have a hold on us.
Lee: See?
[whispers] Werewolves.
Anthony: I just...there's no possible way
for a wolf and a person to coexist in a single
body.
Lee: Can I just have them please?
Anthony: Werewolves are real everybody!
Hey if you're wondering where Laci Green is,
she is over on Sourcefed.
That's where you usually are.
Where's that?
Lee: It's at YouTube.com/sourcefed.
Anthony: So go check that out.
If you want to see Laci, she will be back
in a few days and subscribe here for mroe
Dnews.
Lee: Bye